Dearest reader,
did you miss me?
Forgive me, Mama.
Might I go promenade
for suitors with Eloise?
She has named Daphne
as the season's
Incomparable.
She calls you "a diamond
of the first water."
Flawless, my dear.
I was smiling at the view,
which you are now blocking.
Mrs Thatcher.
Your Majesty.
-Oh, Newton. Newton!
-Newton!
Over.
Best of luck to you, Robert.
You shall certainly need it
this season.
Which one is your pick,
my lord?
-Edwina.
-Nectar.
Action!
Come on! Come on!
Here, allow me.
A pleasing face,
an acceptable wit
and genteel manners enough
to credit a viscountess.
That should not be
so hard to find.
Do not tell us you are
hoping for a love match.
Love is the last thing
I desire.
But if my children
are to be of good stock,
then their mother must be
of impeccable quality.
Mr Finch.
Pardon me,
Miss Featherington.
Oh, what a delectable frock.
Almost the exact shade
of Double Gloucester
your mother served
at tea this afternoon.
I so love cheese.
Oh, I do relish a challenge.
The Mallet of Death.
Would you look at that,
brother?
Is this yours?
No, no.
You're welcome to it.
-You threatened to beat me--
-You exaggerate.
Brother,
might I be able to join in
on the fun this summer
at Aubrey Hall?
Provided you stay clear
of my lucky mallet.
If there is interest,
I can send word
to my men on the ground
in Georgia.
-Ah.
-Very good.
I shall indeed marry
Prudence,
but you should know she's
marrying a penniless man.
My loyalty is to the King
and Prince Arthur.
There is nothing you can do
to change that.
So many flowers,
when what I really seek
is a gem.
When one is frustrated,
it is often much wiser
to focus upon satisfying
one's own needs.
Mama and I did the best
we could to raise Edwina,
all so she would never know
of our struggles.
What do you have
in your hand?
Nothing, Mama.
It's only a pamphlet
on new methods
for the tidying of dogs,
apparently.
I am sorry, Mama, but…
I am attending a lecture
this afternoon.
Flower arranging.
Come on, then.
Is it Mondrich or Gillespie?
Come on, one bet. One bet.
Oh dear!
What can the matter be?